wieder eine schwere explosion auf der
krim diese meldung ist vor wenigen
minuten hier reingekommen wieder im
großen stil offenbar munition explodiert
das brisante an diesen bildern die diese
explosionen zeigen sollen eben das
gebiet auf der krim also auf dem gebiet
das sich putin 2014 unter den nagel
gerissen hat ist das ein ukrainischer
angriff auf russische ziele auf der krim
das wollen wir wissen von unserem bild
militärexperten julian heppt kreationen
sind studio geeilt diese bilder dass mal
was macht dich sicher dass sie
tatsächlich diese explosionen zeigen die
dort stattgefunden haben soll vor
wenigen stunden ja heute morgen um 6 uhr
30 ist das wohl etwa gewesen als es dort
los gingen mit den großen explosionen
ich habe die persönlich eben nochmal
verortet das hat mir angeguckt welche
bäume stehen links und rechts davon
welche straße ist da welcher im
schornstein bei der rechts davon zu
sehen von einer kleinen fabrik und habe
noch mal geguckt das sind also auf jeden
fall bilder aus manisa auf der krim von
heute morgen welche parallelen kannst du
feststellen zwischen diesen ja nur
wenigen tagen auseinanderliegen den
bildern ja wir hatten ja tatsächlich
letzte woche den angriff auf sagt ja so
große explosion wo im gefährt 12
russische flugzeuge zerstört wurden
heute morgen nicht nur in moskau sondern
auch in dinko einige kilometer weiter
nördlich parallel explosionen dort in
einem umspannwerk auf der einen seite
und eben hier in einem munitionsdepot
das sind auf jeden fall parallelen also
ich meine rentiert sich alten bildern
juliane
samstage alt und jetzt kann auch von
letzter woche heute morgen er ähnlich
große explosion sagen wir mal nur wir
hatten heute morgen nicht tausende
touristen die es auf einmal gefilmt
haben sondern es musste erst mal
explodieren kann sich dort bewohner
aufgewacht und haben das gefilmt
vielleicht ganz kurz noch mal zum sinnen
dieser explosion heute morgen dass es
ganz interessant beide explosionen die
stadt gefunden haben waren entlang der
zugstrecke von russland über die krim in
der ukraine und die zugstrecke ist jetzt
gesperrt das heißt es gibt angeblich
schweren schaden an der zugstrecke und
über die krim brücke die von der ukraine
auch schon bedroht wurde wertvoll sei am
morgen keinen zug mehr in richtung
besetzter süd ukraine das heißt die
versorgung könnte auch dort gestört sein
zumindest unterbrochen seien für kurze
zeit zumindest auf die krim nochmal auf
die bilder dieser explosionen die
russische seite sagt ja immer bei diesen
explosionen einer moment mal das sind
hier unfälle
munitionslagern und die ukrainische
seite bestätigt oder beweist auch nicht
dass es sich hier um angriff verhandelt
wieso nicht und was macht dich sicher
dass es oder relativ sicher dass es
trotzdem ukrainische angriffe sind also
ganz richtig die ukraine hat bisher
nicht öffentlich gesagt präsident nicht
öffentlich gesagt das machen sie hier
sondern präsident solvenz gesagt
vorsicht mit dem umgang mit zigaretten
und offenem feuer auf solchen basis das
wäre gerade in den besetzten gebieten
sehr problematisch warum sagt er das ja
das ist eine sehr gute frage wir denken
dass um diese präzisions eingriffe
durchzuführen braucht er westliche
waffen und zwar westliche
präzisionswaffen die über ungefähr 200
kilometer weit schießen könnt
amerikanische raketen amerikanischer
raketen von denen die amerikaner aber
sagen die haben sie nicht geliefert
jetzt ist die frage haben sie vielleicht
jemand anderem in der nähe der ukraine
diese waffen geliefert die dann wiederum
weiter geliefert haben offiziell will
man glaube ich auch da den kreml noch
nicht ganz im klaren lassen aber ich
habe auch gestern mit einem hochrangigen
us beamten gesprochen darüber mit
anderen journalisten im hintergrund und
er hat gesagt ja es gibt berichte dass
es ein unfall ist aber viel mehr
berichte sowie der seine verschnörkelte
art vielmehr berichte deuten darauf hin
dass es sich nicht um einen unfall
gehandelt hat insofern auch die
amerikaner haben die augenzwinkernd
glaube ich gesagt guckt euch die
explosion mal genau an und da steckt
schon ein interessantes muss dahinter
warum gesagt keiner nein es war kein
unfall also die russen haben auch heute
morgen gesagt es ist ein feuer es gibt
keine schweren verlust haben sie aber
keine schweren schäden haben sie gesagt
und sie gucken sich das an
man muss wie gesagt für russland wäre
das ein absolutes desaster zuzugehen das
auf der krim von dem rücken hat gesagt
dass es unsere krim das ist seit 2014
russland dass es dort krieg gibt das war
nämlich zu geben wie gesagt das ist eine
spezialoperation in der ukraine sobald
der krieg auf russischen boden kommt und
das kommt ja wie wert sehen ob wir
faktisch wo sich boden auf die besetzte
krimi würde putin in erklärungsnot
geraten vor seinem wlan bürgern oder
untergebene danke für deine analyse
unser bild militärexperte julian trottel
zu der neuen explosion offenbar durch
eine ukrainischen angriff auf der krim
[Musik]